Guten Morgen Thomas.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Logbuch:Netzpolitik Nummer zweihundertzweiunddreißig und ihr werdet es schon ahnen heute ohne Linus, denn wir haben beschlossen ein kleines Spezial
einzuschieben aufgrund der Terminlage
mache ich das jetzt alleine beziehungsweise alleine mache ich es natürlich nicht, sondern ich begrüße Thomas Lohninger, hallo Thomas.
Hallo.
Genau, du bist ja wie hier wahrscheinlich sowieso alle wissen äh nicht nur aus Österreich, sondern jetzt auch in Österreich und immer in Sachen Österreich unser äh Primärkorrespondent und da auch in deinem zweiten
Haupthobby, äh, Netzneutralität noch einiges
passiert ist, dachte ich kloppen wir daraus einfach mal eine Sendung zusammen, bevor ich dann äh mit Linus dann auch relativ bald
wohl die nächste Sendung auch nochmal nachlegen werde, aber die Nuss konnte heute nicht und du konntest morgen nicht und deswegen ist das jetzt so wie es ist. Stimmt's.
Ja, so ist es.
Ja und bist du noch guter Laune.
Ja, also ähm inzwischen wieder
Ähm, ich ich bin da schon durch die Phasen der Trauer durchgewandert und ähm inzwischen finde ich sehr spannend, äh was was äh im Österreich gerade los ist. Äh wir haben ja gewählt. Ähm letzten Sonntag, am fünfzehnten Oktober hat Österreich einen neuen Nationalrat gewählt und
diese Wahl war ein ziemlicher Erdrutsch
und äh wir sind heute am Donnerstag, wo wir aufzeichnen, gibt's noch kein amtliches Endergebnis, aber,
ist eigentlich schon alles klar, was man wissen muss und das Ergebnis ist auf jeden Fall sagen wir mal diskussionswürdig.
Ist denn das eigentlich normal, dass es bis zum Endergebnis so lange dauert? In Deutschland ist das ja in der Regel schneller. Äh also das vorläufige amtliche Endergebnis zumindest oder wovon sprechen wir jetzt.
Das vorläufige ist schon da, aber du weißt schon Wahlen in Österreich, da gibt's hin und wieder ein bissel Komplikation.
Stimmt, die Aufkleber und so alles Mögliche kann da schiefgehen.
Der böse Kleber aus Deutschland. Ja. Ähm.
Also wir.
Nadel, der Hintergrund ist, dass jetzt noch Wahlkarten sozusagen in das Richtige ähm das richtige Magistrat gebracht werden müssen, um dort final ausgezählt zu werden,
Wir reden noch von circa siebenunddreißigtausend Wahlkarten, die jetzt noch nicht ausgezählt sind. Ähm und es gibt noch äh sozusagen eine Schwankungsbreite von null Komma zwei Prozent. Ähm es ist aber so gut wie ausgeschlossen, dass ich an diesem Wahlergebnis noch e
was ändert.
Also die die Wahrscheinlichkeit ist ist jetzt zu hoch, dass sich nochmal was ändert wie damals bei der Präsidentschaftswahl, dass da irgendwelche gefälschten Wahlkarten zu einem Gewinn von Norbert Hofer geführt hätten, also.
Wir haben ein Ergebnis und das sieht so aus, dass ähm
Die neue Volkspartei diese Wahl klar gewonnen hat ähm die sind hier jetzt habe ich gerade das Ergebnis nicht vor mir aber.
Die neue Volkspartei.
Ja, die haben sich umbenannt, äh die Parteifarbe ist jetzt auch nicht mehr schwarz, sondern türkis
ähm äh neue Volkspartei ist auch nur ein Teil des Namens, der andere Namen ist Liste Sebastian Kurz.
Ähm Sebastian Kurz äh haben wir hier im Podcast schon mal diskutiert, dass sozusagen der neue ähm Chef der ÖVP und auch äh mit sehr hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit unser neuer Bundeskanzler, ist einunddreißig Jahre alt.
Und bisheriger Außenminister muss man dazu sagen.
Genau und davor war Staatssekretär für Integration und er ist äh so der Rising Star der österreichischen Politiklandschaft. Am Anfang wurde ein bissel ausgelacht wegen seinem Alter und seiner Ohren. Inzwischen lacht glaube ich niemand mehr über ihn
und der ist sozusagen jetzt in einer also Sebastian Kurz war auch ein starkes Wahlmotiv für viele Leute.
Also der hat ein ein sehr starken Negativtrend der konservativen in Österreich, den seit vielen Jahren gab gestoppt und jetzt sind sie wieder als Erster durchs Ziel gelaufen.
Immerhin, sieben, siebeneinhalb Prozent mehr. Mhm.
Und ähm dann äh ist die, die SPÖ hat es äh noch auf Platz zwei geschafft ähm mit äh ich muss das jetzt alles aus dem Kopf rezipieren, sech.
Sechsundzwanzig Komma acht Prozent. Ich habe das hier, also das amtliche, das vorläufige Endergebnis, da blicke ich drauf genommen.
Ja, wunderbar.
Es ist dann hinter das, das ist mehr als man dachte, die SPÖ war in diesem Wahlkampf sehr stark geplagt von Leaks
ihrer internen E-Mails und von einem Skandal, um dort die Compaining. Das Ganze hatte in gewisser Weise parallel zu US-Wahl, dass da eben auch E-Mails nach außen getragen wurden, diesmal nicht durch irgendeinen russischen Hack
sondern durch eine ähm Mitarbeiterin, die das Ganze dann mitgenommen hat und an an Medien oder eben an
andere Unbekannte, die sich an den Medien geliebt haben,
und das war auf jeden Fall ein sehr turbulenter Wahlkampf, wo es eben auch Debatten gab, um Faceboo.
Die äh den Sebastian Kurz negativ dargestellt haben, aber auch welche, die ihm positiv dargestellt haben
teilweise dann eben sogar mit ähm Antisemitischen Witzen und derartigen Dingen. Ähm,
Affäre rund um Tal Silberstein, einem Politikberater aus Israel, ähm der dem Vernehmen nach äh für die für die SPÖ gearbeitet hat.
Ich rechne mal, dass wir dazu einen Untersuchungsausschuss haben werden in der nächsten Legislaturperiode,
diesen Skandal der Nähe anschaut. Aber ja das heißt die SPÖ hat's trotzdem noch auf Platz zwei geschafft ähm und dahinter ist die F.
Eben sechsundzwanzig Prozent bekommen hat, ähm,
und die es wahrscheinlichste die wahrscheinlichste Koalition wird auch zwischen konservativen und der FPÖ sein, der äh rechtspopulistischen, rechtsextremen Parteien Österrei.
Und das ist aber noch nicht alles vom Ergebnis, also wir haben.
Die NEOS, die unsere FDP, die Liberalen haben es haben den Einzug geschafft
Liste Pilz hat ebenfalls den Einzug geschafft, dass es eine Abspaltung äh der grünen Partei oder von einem ehemaligen Gründungsmitglied der Grünen, der dreißig Jahre für die Grünen im Parlament war und dann nicht den Listenplatz bekam, den er wollte,
also statt vier, Platz sechs
das hat ihn so aufgeregt und auch wahrscheinlich ein paar andere Dinge, dass er dann eben eine neue Partei gegründet hat und die haben den Einzug geschafft, die klassischen Grünen in Österreich sind nach dreißig Jahren aus dem Parlament geflogen.
Ach, aber warte mal diese Pilz, das ist dieser Peter Pilz, ne? Ähm sind jetzt laut dem vorläufigen Endergebnis bei vier Komma drei sieben Prozent gelandet. Wo ist denn die Grenze.
Wir haben eine vier Prozent Tüte.
Ah ja, okay.
Weswegen die Grünen auch mit drei Komma acht es nicht mehr schaffen werden und auch wenn's noch eine Schwankungsbreite von null Komma zwei Prozent gibt ähm,
es ist wie gesagt statistisch so gut wie ausgeschlossen,
da jetzt noch der Einzug geschafft wird und die ähm circa hundertzwanzig Mitarbeiter der Grünen Bundespartei wurden auch schon beim Arbeitsmarktservice angemeldet, äh sprich hier werden jetzt
Hier ist man schon am Rückzug und am am am am Abwickeln dieser Bundespartei.
Die auch nach den letzten Wahlkämpfen, die ja auch sehr lange gedauert haben, auch noch auf einem riesigen Berg Schulden steckt. Äh sitzt uns äh da ist da ist schon,
viel Struktur verloren gegangen. Die Grünen waren definitiv einer der konstruktivsten Kräfte im österreichischen Parlamentarismus.
Und äh haben's aber aufgrund einer Verkettung von äh wirklich äh ja für sie sehr negativen Ereignissen nicht geschafft, da jetzt groß zu mobilisieren. Sie haben auch irgendwie nochmal.
War hundertneunzigtausend Wähler an die SPÖ verloren ähm und auch wenn man Peter Pilz und die Grünen zusammenzählt, in ihren Wählerstimmen hätten sie trotzdem.
Erbeverluste eingefahren im Vergleich zur letzten Nationalratswahl zweitausenddreizehn. Also da ist wirklich vieles schief gelaufen und,
stellt sich da jetzt die große Sinnfrage, wie es mit denen weitergeht, das dominiert auch gerade die innenpolitische Debatte in Österreich. Ähm Deutschland gab's ja schon mal sowas, dass die Grünen rausgeflogen sind, in Österreich ist das neu.
Und ja das alles eben vor einem Hintergrund, dass wir.
Jetzt sehr wahrscheinlich eine türkisblaue Regierung haben werden.
Auch das hatten wir schon mal zweitausend. Äh damals gab's EU-Sanktionen gegen Österreich. Mit denen ist dieses Mal nicht mehr zu rechnen, weil das ähm.
Populisten in in Europa die Regierung stellen, daran hat man sich gewöhnt und es wird wirklich spannend, wie das weitergehen wird, weil es auch anzunehmen ist, dass dass man sich hier.
In vielen Dingen versucht Österreich neu zu bauen. Also sowas wie.
Sozialsystem in Österreich, die die Pflichtmitgliedschaft in den Sozialpartnerschaften, die in Österreich die Basis für viele arbeitsrechtliche Absicherungen für Mindestlöhne und so weiter sind, die soll aufgehoben werden.
Das wäre ein sehr drastischer Einschnitt. Es gibt auch Debatten um eine Neuausrichtung von Österreich.
Nicht mehr Richtung Westen, sondern Richtung Osten, Richtung Wischegrad starten. Ähm die äh Migrationspolitik, die Österreich fahrt, ist ja schon sehr ähnlich
der von Ungarn. Ähm, es gab äh skurrile Momente in diesem Wahlkampf, wo sich irgendwie Sebastian Kurz und Heinz Christian Strache, der Chef der Rechtspopulisten darum gebettelt haben, im Live-Fernsehduell, wer jetzt Viktor Orban besser kennt.
Ähm also.
Aber das das also das jetzt die ähm die ÖVP oder wie nennt die sich jetzt? NVP oder was?
Die ÖVP, nein, neue Volkspartei, du kannst die ÖVP nennen, tun, tun, die meisten Leute.
Okay.
Also in der Wikipedia sind sie auch noch schwarz, also das mit dem Türkis scheint sie noch nicht so rumgesprochen zu haben. Ähm, auf jeden Fall, dass die jetzt mit der FPÖ zusammengehen wollen, war das von vornherein erklärtes Ziel.
War das sozusagen nur jetzt klar, weil die SPÖ gesagt hat, sie will nicht mehr oder wollen wollen wollen, also wer will die alte Koalition nicht fortsetzen? Beide nicht.
Ich glaube niemand in Österreich will weiterhin eine eine große Koalition von äh schwarz und rot. Äh das hatte Österreich über die längste Zeit äh und es hat,
ähm nur zu ewigem Stillstand geführt, deswegen gibt's da sozusagen auch einen starken Wunsch nach Veränderung. Ähm also das heißt äh die klassische große Koalition, die ja heute gar nicht mehr so groß wäre,
es ist bei vielen Leuten das, äh, was was man sozusagen jetzt lang genug probiert hat, das kann's nicht mehr sein und dann bleibt halt rechnerisch nur noch eine Koalition mit der,
da äh gibt's jetzt auch äh eine riesige Debatte da drum, vor allem eben bei den Sozialdemokraten
Eigentlich gab es in in Österreich immer die sogenannte Franitzkiduk drin, ähm das heißt keine Koalition der Sozialdemokraten mit äh den den Rechtsextremen.
Wollte man sich immer davon abgrenzen
ähnlich wie die Union vorher gesagt hat, rechts von uns darf es nichts geben oder wir würden zum Beispiel nicht mit denen koalieren und die bricht jetzt
an vielen Stellen. Es gibt schon Landesregierungen, wo in dem Fall
die SPÖ mit der FPÖ in Koalition ist. Ähm! Gerade aus diesen Teilen Österreichs kommt dann eben auch der starke Wunsch sich jetzt andere strategische Optionen aufzumachen und auch mit der FPÖ auf Bundesebene zu koalieren,
hält im Moment noch Wien dagegen. Als äh größtes ähm Bundesland, äh was auch äh den den diesen,
Abrutscht der SPÖ, der ansonsten passiert wäre, aufgehalten hat und da gibt's den Bürgermeister Michael Holpe, der immer noch eine ganz starke Ablehnung äh dieser Position hat.
Im Moment taktiert man halt. Im Moment will man natürlich auch nicht äh diese diese Strategiekompetenz zu machen. Das hat aber natürlich auch den fallen Beigeschmack
äh dass die SPÖ jetzt hier nicht eine klare Oppositionsansage macht, ähm wie es hier in Deutschland passiert ist und und wie ich auch finde, dass es dass es klar.
Da jetzt weiter herum zu taktieren, das ist das große Problem der Sozialdemokraten. Sie schaffen es nicht, ihre Flügelkämpfe aufzulösen, egal ob das das Sicherheitsthema ist, das Überwachungsthema.
Die Migrations oder Ausländerfrage in Österreich bei all diesen Themen,
versucht mit irgendwie so einen Eiertanz äh zu machen und beide Flügel zufriedenzustellen und am Ende keine klare Position zu beziehen.
Und das ist glaube ich immer Gift, wenn man sozusagen Politik macht ohne Meinung zu haben, ohne Positionen zu vertreten
Aber genau das passiert jetzt gerade hier und ähm sobald jetzt das amtliche Endergebnis da ist, gibt's einen Auftrag zur Regierungsbildung, den der Bundespräsident,
Sebastian Kurz aussprechen wird und dann wird verhandelt. Theoretisch sind drei Optionen denkbar, eben ähm wahrscheinlich e.
Großen jeweils zwei, genau, aber das SPÖ und FPÖ hier zusammengehen, kann man doch wohl eher ausschließen, oder?
Zumindest nicht unter dem derzeitigen
noch Bundeskanzler, äh, Parteivorsitzenden Sebastian Kern, der würde das, glaube ich, nicht machen. Es gäbe da irgendwie so Leute, die ihn vom Thron stürzen wollen,
aus dem Bugenland, aber ob die das schaffen würden, vor allem dann auch durch den die Parteigremien sich so eine Koalition absegnen zu lassen
halte ich für sehr unwahrschein.
Ja zumal er ja auch jetzt sein, sein äh den Wahlanteil ja quasi gehalten hat, ne? Also.
Ist ja nicht so, dass es jetzt so so ein so ein so eine historische Niederlage wäre, wie für die SPD in äh Deutschland. Ja
ähm blicken wir dann doch mal auf die Oppositionsseite, also dadurch, dass die Grünen wegfallen, das ist natürlich hart, auch wenn man wahrscheinlich davon ausgehen kann, dass so ein paar dieser Mitarbeiter sicherlich dann bei der Pilzpartei auftauchen oder ist das jetzt wieder so ein revolutionärer Zerfleischung im linken Lager, dass dass das alles komplett neu sich aufstellt.
Das wird man sehen müssen. Also.
Die Liste Pilz lebt im Moment sehr stark von ihrem Spitzenkandidaten. Und ähm wie gesagt, der war dreißig Jahre lang in dieser Partei für sie im Nationalrat.
Und war, ist natürlich.
Gründer, oder?
Ich glaube ja und dadurch ist äh da schon eine starke Verbindung da, die natürlich jetzt durch diesen Austritt und diese Gegenkanitatur auch sicherlich in inschaft übergeschlagen hat. Ob das,
gekittet werden kann und man da pragmatisch ist oder ob hier Fundamentalopposition angesagt ist, weiß ich nicht inhaltlich.
Gibt schon kleine Unterschiede, wobei das ist vor allem im äh den Ausrichtungsfragen. Also ähm Peter Pilz hat auch teilweise.
Ähm.
Weiß gar nicht, ob man das rechts rechte Rhetorik nennen kann, aber für ihn war zum Beispiel auch politischer Islam ein ganz starkes Thema. Ja, da da gibt's definitiv auch ähm.
Glaube ich schon noch reale Probleme. Gleichzeitig ist es natürlich in der Art wie es bringt führt's wiederum zu Gegenreaktionen von anderen Lagern.
Und man wird jetzt sehen sozusagen welche Politik die Liste Pilz machen wird es ist
zu hoffen, dass sich möglichst viele konstruktive Kräfte da wieder verbinden werden, weil es braucht natürlich eine eine starke innerparlamentarische äh linke Kraft auch, ja? Ansonsten ist da nicht mehr so viel übrig.
Und.
Wie gesagt, aber was dann wirklich für Politik gemacht wird, wird spannend sein. Angeblich hat die Liste Pilz auch keinen Clubzwang. Ähm hatten die Grünen auch nicht laut, laut äh Statut, ob das dann wirklich in der Praxis so gelebt wird, wird man sehen.
Was was ist der Clubzwang.
Der Clubzwang ist die, die was glaube ich bei euch Fraktionsdisziplin ist, also dass die Abgeordneten immer mit ihrer Partei stimmen.
Sollen müssen, ähm das ist eigentlich in Österreich verfassungswidrig, in der Verfassung sind die Abgeordneten nur ihrem Gewissen verpflichte.
Ja in Deutschland ja auch.
De facto äh hast du wirklich mit enormen Konsequenzen zu rechnen, wenn man als Abgeordneter gegen die jagene Partei stimmt, dann geht das von, du wirst am Gang nicht mehr gegrüßt, du wirst zu Sitzungen nicht mehr eingeladen, bist zu,
härtesten auch öffentlichen Konsequenzen, dass man Leuten über die Medien ausrichtet, was für böse Menschen sie nicht sind.
Gab's schöne Beispiele, also sehr schlimme Beispiele in Österreich, Sonja Ablinger, die das mal innerhalb der SPÖ gemacht hat.
Man wird sehen sozusagen wie, wie frei und flexibel ist diese Liste Pilz wirklich ähm.
Es ist zu hoffen, dass sie für die Bürgerrechte und für Netzpolitik progressive Positionen.
Vertreten werden, ähm! Weil Peter Pilz auch immer ein starker Kämpfer gegen den Überwachungsstaat war, wie sie dann zum Beispiel bei Urheberrechtsthemen sich positionieren werden, wird spannend, weil es gibt so Leute,
wie einfach neu auf der Liste die eher so als Hardliner im Ohrbereich Überrechtsbereich bekannt waren.
Da da wird man sehen sozusagen wie die sich da positionieren. Es sind doch viele Newcomer in dieser.
Was ist von dieser NEOS Gruppierung zu erwarten.
Ja, die NEOS sind so eine klassische ähm,
zu klassische neoliberale Partei, ja? Sind sich im liberalen Spektrum, sind definitiv gut für Bürgerrechte, da haben sie auch einen sehr guten Checkrecords, sind auch in ihrer parlamentarischen Arbeit.
Immer sehr stark gewesen, also also als Kontrollkraft
Ähm und äh ja, also die sie äh haben eben geplant, Wirtschaftsprogramm, was was man als liberal einschätzen kann.
Sie setzen stark auf Bildung,
Sie haben sich jetzt zuletzt nochmal ein bisschen verbreitet, indem sie Irmgard Chris auf ihre Liste geholt haben, das ist die unabhängige Kandidatin für das Amt des Bundespräsidenten, der Bundespräsidentin, die,
achtzehn Prozent ein sehr starkes Ergebnis aus unabhängiger angesagt hat, äh die wird jetzt auch für sie in den Nationalrat einziehen.
Und äh NEOS äh sind sind jetzt auch eben in dieser äh Liste an an äh Parteien, die einer Zweidrittelmehrheit
verschaffen können. Also in Österreich ähm braucht man natürlich eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit für Verfassungsänderungen. Die haben die großen
Koalitionsoptionen derzeit nicht, die jeweils mit zwei Parteien sind, das heißt, da brauchen sie noch eine dritte Partei und es ist gibt auf jeden Fall viele Fragen, wo es spannende Verfassungsmehrheiten gibt, wenn.
Schwarz, blau und türkis, also NEOS sich da zusammentun.
Die NEOS sind auch türkis.
Nein nein Hello Kitty ist die Farbe die sie da haben. Pink Pink genau ja.
Na, das ist ja sehr übersichtlich. Meine Herren, das heißt, also äh die Grünen sind sozusagen auf dem Weg der judäischen Volksfront und der Volksfront von Judäa äh untergegangen, kann man sagen.
Ja, also diese Abspaltung wurde schon aktiv vom Pitter Pilz betrieben, also da haben die Grünen schon versucht, irgendwie das zu verhindern und zusammenzuhalten, aber da gab's glaube ich auch schon länger vorbereitet, eben Pläne,
sich abzuspalten äh und äh ja, jetzt haben wir auf jeden Fall sozusagen,
Die klassischen Gründe sind rausgefahren, Liste Pilz würde ich mal als neue Partei ansehen, ob die das Erbe der Grünen antreten.
In ein paar Jahren sehen, vor allem wenn sie dann in fünf Jahren nochmal kandidieren und den Einzug schaffen, dann kann man vielleicht davon sprechen.
Meine Herren, das ist ja eine richtige richtiges Schlachtfest gewesen.
Ne, vor allem ist ja dann sozusagen auch überhaupt gar keine nennenswerte linke Opposition mehr zu erkennen, ne? Also wenn man da äh selbst wenn man noch die Neos da mit reinzählt, was wahrscheinlich schon ein Fehler wäre, kommt man am bestenfalls auf zehn Prozent der Sitze.
Ist denn vielleicht nochmal kurz mit der SPÖ? Also meinst, du meintest ja gerade, sie sind nicht so.
Wie soll ich sagen, noch nicht so auf dem Weg in die fundamentale Opposition, aber das werden sie ja dann zwangsläufig sein, sollte sich die ÖVP, wie das zu erwarten ist, mit der FPÖ einigen können.
Ja ähm das wird auch spannend, wie sie sozusagen aus der Opposition heraus agieren, ähm der Spitzenkandidat Sebastian Kern hat angekündigt, dass er ähm weiterhin ähm
in der, in der Politik bleiben wird, das heißt, dass er auch in die Opposition geht, dass wir davor irgendwie ein bissel parkwürdig.
Und ja, aber diese Rolle es ist sicherlich neu für sie, ich meine das hatten sie schon mal, dass wir schon mal ähm eine eine,
FPÖ ÖVP Regierung hatten. Die Frage ist halt jetzt, wie sie das fühlen werden und ähm.
Ich befürchte, dass ähm sich viel an der Struktur von Österreich ändern wird, wenn diese Regierung
kommt und es wird dann an der SPÖ sein, da gute Oppositionsarbeit zu machen und äh nach Möglichkeit äh dann irgendwie einen Abbau des Sozialstaates entgegenzuwirken.
So gut sieht das dann halt noch kann.
Dass das Wichtigste ist für uns immer, dass man nicht anfangt an rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien zu rücken, wie wir das ja eben teilweise schon in Polen und in Ungarn sehen.
Wie gesagt, der Zuspruch Richtung Visegrad starten. Auch von der ÖVP ist teilweise sehr explizit.
Und es gibt da sehr besorgniserregende Tendenzen und wenn man sich das im europäischen Kontext anschaut, wir haben schon jetzt das Problem, dass wir äh europäische,
Maßnahmen und Sanktionen gegen Polen aufgrund der der Abbaus von dem Verfassungsgerichtshof dort und der wirklichen politischen Einflussnahme in in.
Das das Rechtssystem dass man die nichts entgegensetzen kann, weil Ungarn da blockiert.
Jetzt könnte Österreich sozusagen sich diesen Blog anschließen und dann sieht's wirklich sehr schlecht aus für die Bürgerrechte in Österreich. Also das ist für uns auch eine klare rote Linie, wenn man hier anfangt irgendwie politischer Einflussnahme,
auf auf die unabhängige Justiz auszuüben, wenn der die Höchstgerichte destoniert oder abgebaut werden,
wenn man versucht Gesetze mutwillig in Verfassungsraum zu heben, obwohl die da nicht hingehören, um sie einfach auch dem Zugriff des Verfassungsgerichtshofs zu entziehen.
Dann sind eindeutig rote Linien stark überschritten, natürlich auch wenn irgendwie Presse und Medienfreiheit eingeschränkt wird,
Ähm und ähm wir haben wir haben kürzlich in weißer Voraussicht einen Solidaritätspakt der Zivilgesellschaft in Österreich gegründet. Sowas wie eine NGO-NATO, also wenn gegen eine,
NGO vorgegangen wird, dann kommen die anderen zum Beistand.
Sollte da sozusagen auch die die aktive Zivilgesellschaft ins Fadenkreuz kommen, dann dann haben wir uns schon mit anderen großen NGOs zusammen geschlossen
Ich hoffe, wir werden sowas nicht brauchen, aber falls es wirklich schlimm wird, dann sind wir bereit, ich meine, Österreich hatte so eine Regierung schon mal. Und äh,
wir leben jetzt schon in anderen Zeiten, aber ich glaube, man darf da äh die Prinzipien keinesfalls irgendwie an die neuen politischen Gegebenheiten anpassen, sondern man muss weiter auf auf Rechtsstaatlichkeit beharren.
Ja, so wie es jetzt ausschaut, äh, fehlen der FPÖ und ÖVP Koalition
neuen Mandate auf eine Verfassungsmehrheit. Das heißt, das ist zumindest schon mal gut, das heißt, dass sie da nicht im Alleingang ähm durchregieren können.
Wir haben in Österreich keine zweite Kammer, das heißt es gibt nicht sowas wie eine Sperre die die rein realistisch durch die Bundesländer ausgeübt werden kann. Ähm.
Das heißt, ähm, das wird alles im Nationalrat sehr spannend, die nächsten fünf Jahre.
Ja, wobei ist der Bundesrat ja jetzt auch nicht unbedingt gerade ein Bollwerk gegen äh.
Entsprechende Änderungen des Systems darstellt, ne? Ähm.
Ja, da kriegt er äh die alte Sage von Österreich, Ungarn, eine ganz neue Bedeutung, ne? Also wenn sich diese Achse tatsächlich auftun würde, dann äh wird sicherlich auf europäischer Ebene nicht einfacher.
Wie sieht denn das jetzt sozusagen aus deiner spezifischen Netzpolitischen
klange schon an, Bürgerrechtsperspektive, also inwiefern kann man da äh also was für Projek.
Die jetzt ohnehin schon umstritten waren, drohen jetzt wieder auf den Tisch zu kommen oder in anderer Ausrichtung angenommen zu werden oder ist das noch zu früh, das zu sagen?
Also ich glaube, das werden jetzt die Koalitionsverhandlungen zeigen. Ähm zu befürchten ist, dass es ein neues
sogenanntes Sicherheitspaket geben wird ähm
Darüber haben wir ja auch schon gesprochen, Sicherheitspaket das Überwachungspaket, wie wir es lieber nennen, konnten wir ja nach sieben Monate langer intensiver Kampagne verhindern, dass es vor der Wahl nicht mehr gekommen ähm
kann ich mir aber gut vorstellen, dass das Teil des Koalitionsvertrags sein wird und dass man da wieder versucht, äh den den Faden aufzugreifen.
Das Wahlenpaket von Maßnahmen, die sehr stark eben auf auf Überwachung, teils auch auf Massenüberwachung setzen, Legalisierung von Bundestrojaner, Vorratsdaten, Speicherung und ganz viele andere lustige Sachen. Das konnten wir verhindern
das hat auch die FPÖ abgelehnt in der letzten Regierung und es wird halt spannend zu sehen, ob sie jetzt, wo sie,
die zu hoher Wahrscheinlichkeit des Innenresorts sich besorgen werden, vielleicht auch das Justizresort weiterhin gegen solche Maßnahmen sind.
Mit welcher, mit welcher Argumentation waren die denn dagegen?
Das ist ganz lustig. Also die FPÖ ist ja eine Partei, die eine starke Tradition mit den Burschenschaften hat. Äh erst recht seitdem Heider sich da abgespalten hat, war der Burschenschaftlerflügel innerhalb der FPÖ sehr stark.
Und ähm die haben da gibt's so zwei Erzählungen dafür. Das eine ist die,
die man gerne von der Richtung hört, dass sie eben auf ihre Tradition, achtzehn achtundvierzig,
Bürgerrechte, wo die Burschenschaften irgendwie aufgestanden sind und rübergerechte eingetreten sind, dass das noch in ihnen lebt. Ähm es gibt doch sicherlich einen äh gewissen Kern an National äh Liberalen innerhalb,
die äh für die Rechtsstaatlichkeit wichtig ist, äh die die äh auch einen äh nicht zu starken Staat haben wollen, der ihnen nicht in
ihre Privatsphäre in ihren,
privaten Bereich reinregiert, reinschauen kann. Ähm und gleichzeitig gibt's aber natürlich auch eine gewisse Nähe zu Burschenschaften und äh zu auch äh Neonarzistischen.
Ähm
Gruppierungen, auch da gibt's äh in den letzten Jahren ja immer wieder Skandale. Man muss sagen, dass diese Leute dann auch immer ausgeschlossen wurden aus der Partei, aber es gab so viele von diesen Skandalen, dass das Nahverhältnis glaube ich unbestreitbar ist und dadurch gibt's natürlich auch sozusagen,
eine gewisse Angst, dass eigene Vorfeldorganisationen ins Fadenkreuz solcher staatlicher Überwachungsmaßnahmen kommen. Nach außen hin ist die FPÖ aber eine klassische Loint-Order-Partei, die das Sicherheitsthema auch,
viele Jahre lang als ihr Thema gesehen hat in dem Thema auch die meiste,
Zustimmung und das meiste Vertrauen hatte äh und das konnte die ÖVP aber in den letzten äh Monaten an sich reißen, gerade durch Innenminister Sobotka, der wirklich so.
Alle Extremste an Innenminister der Learn Order Fraktion ist, was man sich vorstellen kann. Der hat es geschafft, dieses Thema ein bisschen von der FPÖ zur ÖVP-Seite,
ziehen. Ähm, und deswegen wird's für die FPÖ auch so wichtig, dieses Resort für sich zurückzuholen, um da die Themenführerschaft nicht an die Konservativen abgeben zu müssen ähm und äh dadurch liegt das sozusagen auch in in ihrer Hand
aber wird sicherlich bei den Koalitionsverhandlungen jetzt auch ausgedealt werden
sobald es einen Koalitionsvertrag gibt oder auch wahrscheinlich schon während den Verhandlungen werden wir uns das als Epicenter Works sicherlich da einbringen, wir werden Analysen schreiben, wir werden.
Mit allen Politikern Gespräche führen, um hier eben auch auf rechtsstaatliche Garantien zu beharren.
Es gibt ja interessante Gegenvorschläge, die wir inzwischen auf den Tisch gebracht haben, was man für die Sicherheit tun könnte, was nicht Massenüberwachung bedeuten würde und was vor allem auch mehr in Richtung
Prävention, soziale Sicherheit und und najazistischer Staat geht, es gäbe ganz viel, was man tun kann gegen Extremismus in einer Gesellschaft, von allen Richtungen
aber es ist halt so, ich sag mal, es wird so Bürgerrechtsorganisationen brauchen in der nächsten Zeit, damit wir dem Sturm da,
gewappnet sind.
Ist denn.
Also es ist schon wirklich erstaunlich. Ich meine, man ist ja man ist ja nun von Österreich äh schon so einiges gewohnt, um das sowieso immer alles schon nochmal so ein bisschen rechter veranlagt ist, aber das äh.
Dass das so sagen wir mal noch weiter nach rechts rücken kann, das äh macht einen schon irgendwie so ein bisschen fassungslos, ne. Also vor allem sind den, man gibt den irgendwelche nennenswerten.
Also ich meine, gibt's denn wirklich richtige Probleme.
Die jetzt hier von der Linken äh ich sage mal vom linken Spektrum und da da würde ich jetzt mal so pauschal die SPÖ auch nochmal mit reinnehmen irgendwie jetzt äh grob vernachlässigt wurde.
Ist eine gute Frage. Ich meine, äh die die ich würde jetzt persönlich sagen mal, dass die SPÖ seit vielen, vielen Jahren keine glaubhafte linke Politik mehr macht, dass sie äh sich in so gut wie keiner Frage wirklich klar positioniert, dass sie auf die äh großen Herausforderungen unserer Zeit keine Antworten hat in den Konzepten, die sie vorlegt, dass sie
so gut wie allen inhaltlichen Fragen einknickt vor der ÖVP und noch im liegen Umfeld sich in so gut wie keine Verhandlung t,
gesetzt hat, ähm und das einfach obwohl sie jetzt die letzten Jahre in der Regierung war äh.
Keine sozialdemokratische Politik in Österreich gemacht wurde und ich ich bin wirklich erstaunt über dieses Wahlergebnis der der SPÖ, weil eigentlich hätten sie nach diesen vielen Jahren Regierungsbeteiligung, wo sie so wenig umgesetzt haben ähm
glaube ich auch ein negativeres Ergebnis selber erwartet, ja? Und äh gerade mit diesem Wahlkampf,
äh sie jetzt sozusagen weiter in einer stabilen sechsundzwanzig äh Prozent äh Lagerverhahn sagt schon irgendwie, dass dass ich da glaube ich auch nicht viel ändern wird, ja?
Und sie, sie haben halt jetzt wieder die Möglichkeit, Oppositionsarbeit zu machen, aber das ist immer leicht, da Positionen zu vertreten, wenn man sie dann nicht wirklich umsetzen muss.
Ja, na gut, ich meine, es hat ja dann auch damit zu tun, welche Politiker dann letzten Endes äh quasi jetzt die
Die nächsten Karrierepfade dort äh anstreben, weil meine, wenn jetzt dieselben Vögel nur ein anderes Lied singen, dann ähm überzeugt das Herr wahrscheinlich auch nicht unbedingt jeden sofort. Auch wenn das vielleicht äh
Zu romantisch gedacht ist von mir.
Ja, also es es werden spannende,
fünf Jahre sollte die ganze Legislaturperiode durchregiert werden, wer ähm
irgendwas für für Bürgerrechte tun will und da auch vielleicht einen Wortstock, der jetzt mit noch
mehr Fokus auf das österreichische Parlament schaut dann äh
kann man uns spenden als Organisation. Ähm wir freuen uns, wenn wir irgendwie die die Mittel bekommen, dass wir äh diese Regierung im Zaum halten. Ich glaube, das ist auch so die positive Lesart von dem, was in den USA passiert für mich, ja.
Jetzt solltest du aber auch nochmal sagen, wer uns ist.
Ja, also ähm Spenden Punkt Epicenter dot works, äh Epicenter Works, Plattform, Grundrechtspolitik ist äh der ehemalige AK Vorrat. Wir sind diejenigen, die sich so für,
Netzpolitik und Bürgerrechte in Österreich einsetzen und äh wir haben Büro mit ähm Mitarbeitern, die sich um äh
diese Dinge kümmern. Wir schreiben viele juristische Analysen, machen Kampagnen, man kennt uns eh von Safety Internet, von Überwachungspaket, AT und von der Verfassungsgabe damals, die die Vorratsdatenspeicherung abgeschafft hat. Äh wir haben einen sehr guten Track Record.
Bis jetzt haben wir fast alles gewonnen an Themen, die wir bearbeitet haben,
und äh wir werden auch sicherlich äh sehr nah dran sein an an diesem Parlament und werden da versuchen ähm nach besten Kräften ähm.
Das Schlimmste zu verhindern und vielleicht sogar ein paar positive Projekte auch noch durchzubringen.
Nochmal eine Nachfrage zu dem fand das eine sehr schöne Formulierung mit der NGO-NATO. Das ist ja ähm
Insofern interessanter ist, dass man ja nun glauben wollen würde, dass eigentlich NGOs äh ohnehin da
schon eine Achse haben sollten, wo zusammengearbeitet und füreinander gekämpft wird. Hat es, hast du den Eindruck
dass das vielleicht doch so bisher noch nicht so war, dass das Bewusstsein dafür noch nicht so da war oder ist es jetzt nur, dass Saxo ist jetzt nur, weil es jetzt sozusagen nochmal eine besondere Wellness äh gibt über das, was ohnehin schon existiert.
Also ich glaube, man muss da schon.
Extra Netzwerke bilden, die sich dann auch aktivieren lassen. So, äh ich nehme ein schönes Beispiel. Es wurde in Österreich ähm diesem Jahr die Versammlungsfreiheit eingeschränkt. Das heißt, Demonstrationen sind jetzt weitaus schwieriger durchzuführen, können auch viel leichter verboten werden
und das ist ein Thema, wo jede NGO und auch viele
nicht organisierte Menschen aus der Zivilgesellschaft direkt betroffen sind. Trotzdem war der Aufschrei bei weitem nicht so laut, wie er hätte sein
können oder sollen. Und in sowas muss man einfach aktive Strukturen haben, die schon organisiert sind, damit man
auf den Knopf drückt und dann wissen alle Bescheid und können ihre Schritte einleiten
Ähm die Prüfung, die Aktivitäten, die dann die einzelnen Gruppen setzen, liegen eh wieder bei ihnen, aber man muss bereit sein, wenn solche Einschnitte kommen,
um dann schnell reagieren zu können, weil das politische Fans der ist oft wirklich nur sehr gering und sehr kurz. Ähm und und
da gehe ich wieder zurück zu den USA, das sehen wir ja auch
obwohl die Regierung wirklich ihr Bestes tut, um um Dinge zu verkacken. Ähm ist nur mit viel organisierter Zivilgesellschaft und Medien und am Ende auch Gerichten geht, äh da die Regierung einen Zaum zu halten.
Netzwerke braucht es einfach, die müssen auch geschärft sein
weil ein ein liberaler demokratischer Staat verteidigt sich nicht von selbst. Und erst recht, wenn,
die Regierung daran schraubt, muss man bereit sein, rote Linien aufzuzeigen und dann noch ganz laut verbalisieren.
Mhm.
Ja gut, finde ich äh finde ich, finde ich einen guten äh Ansatz, vielleicht nochmal ein bisschen konkreter, wenn du sagst, Netzwerke aufbauen, also was heißt denn das, was heißt denn das konkret.
Dass man sich regelmäßig trifft, dass es da so ein, gibt's so ein rotes Telefon.
Es gibt ein rotes Telefon, also das Ganze ist noch im Aufbau. Wir wollten jetzt mal vor der Wahl mit einer Pressekonferenz rausgehen und haben,
dieses initiale Bündnis mit einem auch einem einem Grundsatzpapier mal veröffentlicht, indem auch diese rechtsstaatlichen Prinzipien
festgeschrieben sind, indem es auch Beispiele gibt aus anderen Ländern, wovor wir warnen. Das heißt, der Grundkonsens ist da, der wird dann bald auf einer Website
die noch nicht online ist, niedergeschrieben sein und.
Dann wird das Ganze auch hoffentlich noch wachsen und die Kommunikationskanäle existieren aber schon sollte jetzt etwas passieren. Ähm.
Und äh das das soll sozusagen wirklich ein Grundkonsens sein, der sich nur auf Rechtsstaatlichkeit brit
bezieht und nicht auf andere Dinge, die uns auch wichtig sind. Ähm wir ökologie oder Sozialrechte ähm sondern da geht's wirklich sozusagen um den Handlungsspielraum
an sich und nicht die einzelnen Themen ähm und und das Konzept findet man dann
hoffentlich dieses Jahr noch auf Solidaritätspakt Punkt org und wird äh kann auch gerne kopiert werden an anderen Stellen, wo es vielleicht auch notwendig ist.
Wer nimmt daran teil? Also wenn NGOs sagst, wer ist das dann.
Das sind eben Epicenter Works, Attack ähm Greenpeace, global zweitausend
das Hilfswerk ist dabei also auch so aus dem aus dem sozialen kirchlichen Bereich. Insgesamt sind's glaube ich zwanzig NGOs.
Mhm. Also auch gar nicht jetzt unbedingt nur so netzorientierte oder Netzpolitik orientierte Gruppierungen oder so konkret.
Nein, überhaupt nicht.
Tiwistische Gruppen, sondern es geht schon weiter als das.
Genau, also es sind doch Gewerkschaften dabei und und der bekannteste Fall in Österreich, wo gegen einzelne NGOs
vorgegangen wird, war auch der Tierschützerprozess rund um den VWT, also wo ähm Tierschützer auf einmal in ein terroristisches, kriminelles Eck gerückt werden und mit einem,
Servus coolen Paragraphen, der der Bildung einer kriminellen Organisation angeklagt wurden für hundert Tage im Gefängnis waren,
massiv überwacht wurden, auch mit eingeschleusten ähm V-Leuten, also verdeckten Ermittlern äh und ähm all das hat dann
zu nichts geführt. Am Ende wurden alle äh zehn Angeklagten freigesprochen, aber hier ist schon wirklich der,
Rechtsstaat sehr gebogen wurden und man ist einfach gegen legitim zivilgesellschaftlichen Protest äh so vorgegangen, als wären das alles Terroristen,
das das ist immer noch ein mahnendes Beispiel aus der jüngeren Geschichte. Insofern ist es ganz wichtig, dass man da über den Tälerrand schaut und
und eben sozusagen alle Menschen, die sich äh auf dem Boden der Verfassung demokratisch einbringen, die die haben die Solidarität von anderen zivilgesellschaftlichen Akteuren,
dient und ja ich mein wir wir tun sowas halt auch in weißer Voraussicht, weil
ich ich will der neuen Regierung noch nichts unterstellen, man muss immer neutral bleiben gegenüber ähm gewählten Volksvertretern finde ich, aber sollte es irgendwie in eine schlechte Richtung abdriften, dann sind wir bereit.
Gut, ich wünsche euch da auf jeden Fall äh viel Erfolg und viel Durchhaltevermögen. Meine Güte und das sind dann auch noch gleich fünf Jahre und nicht vier. Na ja,
Ähm kommen wir zu
anderen Begebenheiten in Deutschland. Du warst ja auch äh habe ich ja auch Eingang schon erwähnt. Wissen ja eigentlich auch alle, aber kann man ja vielleicht trotzdem nochmal bestätigen äh schon seit Jahren in Sachen Netzneutralität unterwegs, hast es,
äh den ganzen Prozess in auf EU-Ebene begleitet und natürlich auch national und hassi aber auch in Deutschland eingemischt, äh, jüngst erst wieder durch deine äh schöne Rede auf der Telekom
äh Aktienaktionärsversammlung. Schönes Ding. Und es geht um den Tarifstream on,
steht in der Kritik ähm.
Quasi mit all diesen frisch geschlossenen Prinzipien der Netzneutralität zu brechen oder zu, also was heißt mit all den, aber zumindest mit dem Prinzip an sich zu brechen, weil dieser Tarif, der eben.
Quasi zwar,
offiziell natürlich kostenlos, aber immerhin Vertragsgebunden bestimmten Anbietern die Möglichkeit bietet empfangen zu werden von den Kunden in diesem Tarif, ohne dass das von den Volumengebühren abgeht, sprich alle anderen, die keinen Vertrag haben.
Laufen dann zwangsläufig in eine Grenze. Ähm.
Da wurde jetzt lange darauf gewartet, dass ja auch bitte sich mal die Bundesnetzagentur dazu äh äußern sollte, da die ja hier quasi als aktiver Körper
des Regulierers äh fungiert und dazu natürlich eine Meinung haben musste. Das hat dann sehr, sehr, sehr lange gedauert. Und jetzt äh.
Kam sie mit ihrem Beschluss dann endlich mal raus. Ist also schön pünktlich nach den Wahlen. Man ja, also schämen wer da Böses äh äh denkt, aber auffällig war das schon, dass es zu lange gedauert hat.
Und meint natürlich, das wäre alles super. Ja.
Es gab Dinge, die kritisiert wurden, aber im Wesentlichen kann man doch sagen, hat die Bundesnetzagentur hier Stream-On eigentlich äh freien Lauf gegeben, oder?
Da muss man näher hinschauen. Also was hier passiert ist, ist, dass die Bundesnetzagentur, nachdem sie über fünf Monate lang nachgedacht hat, nachgedacht hat, nachgedacht hat und eigentlich ähm,
wahrscheinlich unter sehr vielen politischen Druck stand vor der Wahl nichts mehr zu tun. Ähm dann jetzt doch vor vor ein paar Wochen ähm.
Einen Brief an die Deutsche Telekom geschickt hat, auf Basis von Paragraph hundertsechsundzwanzig des deutschen Telekommunikationsgesetzes Untersagung.
Im Grunde hat sie Stream onf ihrer Prüfung bei einigen Stellen äh eben,
sagt das widerspricht gegen geltendes EU-Recht und deswegen muss es untersagt werden. Ihr habt jetzt hier eine Frist, in der ihr nachbessern könnt.
Diese Frist kann wahrscheinlich nochmal verlängert werden, da kann man noch herumstreiten aber der Tarif so wie er jetzt ist kann auf jeden Fall nicht bestehen bleiben
Die Frage ist, äh worin genau liegt jetzt sozusagen das Problem mit mit Stream on. Wir haben ja immer gesagt, es gibt
ähm Dinge, die die ganz klar sind und Dinge, die Case Barcase sind, also die Drosselung, die bei äh dem mittleren Tarif von Stream on ist
ähm da wo Video auf die äh tolle DVD-Qualität äh der zweitausender Jahre reduziert wird. Das ist klar ein Verstoß gegen äh die EU Netzautralitäten. Da gibt's gar keine Frage. Das hätte man irgendwie in einer Woche untersagen können.
Und dann gibt's das wo man näher hinschauen muss, wo wir aber auch klar sagen, das kann nur illegal sein. Angesichts der niedrigen Datenvolumen in Deutschland. Ähm also was wird jetzt passieren, diese Untersagung? Ähm darauf muss die Telekom reagieren.
Den genauen Text dieser Untersagung kennen wir nicht, da ist nur durch die Medien ein bissel was nach außen gesickert
Ähm und wo die Bundesnetzagentur auch auf jeden Fall klar moniert hat, ist das Stream-On ja nicht im europäischen Ausland funktioniert, sondern nur innerhalb von Deutschland. Und das widerspricht klar
den äh Bedingungen der ähm der Roaming-Verordnung, die ja dieselbe Verordnung ist, wie Netzneutralität,
Wir erinnern uns an diesen Treppenwitz, dass man politisch Netzeutralität und Roaming äh zusammengezogen hat, hineingesetzt und auch gegeneinander abgedeilt hat. Also wir nehmen der Telekomindustrie bei Netzzentralität.
Wie bei Perfoming ein bisschen was weg und dafür geben wir ihnen Lack Lachsare Netzneutralitätsregeln. Und der Treppenwitz ist jetzt, dass sich das scheinbar errechnen könnte und dass äh sozusagen das Roaming ähm.
Dann eben auch für die Serating-Tarife gelten muss. Das heißt, ich muss Stream-On auch äh in Österreich, in Frankreich, wo auch immer ich bin, nutzen können und äh das Datenvolumen von zum Beispiel YouTube,
dass ich über äh Stream On in Frankreich nutze, darf nicht gegen mein normales Datenvolumen gezählt werden.
Da gibt's auch schon lustige Artikel auf Golim, die das analysieren und und die haben im Grundsatz Recht, was da aber übersehen wird ist, es gibt ja,
obwohl wir jetzt äh es gibt ja immer noch Warming-Grenzen,
Es gibt ja immer noch eine ähm Begrenzung für das Datenvolumen, was sich im europäischen Ausland äh verwenden darf.
Das bemisst sich nach einer interessanten Formel, also da muss man den Nettopreis des Tarifs nehmen,
also das Kundengeld pro Monat, das dividiert man durch sieben Komma sieben mal zwei und das sind die Egobyte, die man im europäischen Ausland nutzen darf.
Ähm und äh das ist teilweise jetzt schon über dem normalen Daten äh Guthaben, was die Magenta-Tarife der deutschen Telekom haben. Es liegt so in dem Bereich für den Stream und gibt's äh.
Jetzt aus dem Kopf irgendwo zwischen acht und äh fünfzehn Gigabyte. Ähm und die, das darf man sozusagen nutzen,
an Roming Guthaben und das ließe sich dann eben auch für Stream on Geseurate Dienste ähm komplett gratis nutzen.
Und wie gesagt, es ist interessant zu sehen, dass du schon über dem eigentlichen Datenguthaben der Marenther-Tarife liegt.
Und das heißt die Telekom wird jetzt hier von zwei Seiten angegriffen, einerseits in den mittleren Tarifen, wo sie den Leuten ja nur irgendwie ganz wenig gratis Videodatenvolumen geben wollte, durch diese Drossel, da fällt wahrscheinlich die Drossel weg
da müssen sie diesen Leuten auf einmal viel mehr äh an an gratis Datenvolumen schenk,
Mhm. Und gleichzeitig haben sie durch das Roaming jetzt äh höhere Kosten, weil wenn die da ein Kunde der deutschen Telekom irgendwo im europäischen Ausland jetzt äh über die Nacht ganz viel YouTube schaut.
Dann muss die deutsche Telekom dem lokalen Netzbetreiber Geld zahlen, sogenannte Vorleistungsentgelte.
Und das wird sich auch jedes äh jedes Jahr wird das mehr, diese ähm Zahl sieben Komma sieben in der vorher genannten Formel wird immer pro Jahr weniger, bis sie irgendwann einmal zwei Komma zwei Euro pro Gigabyte betragen wird,
das heißt die Kosten für die europäischen Vorlasten sind Geld werden immer niedriger, das heißt wir kriegen pro Jahr mehr Datenvolumen, was wir in Europa nutzen können.
Und.
Wann läuft das aus? Also ist das dann irgendwann mal an so einem Punkt, wo man überhaupt nichts mehr extra zahlt oder keine Einschränkungen hat.
Ja, ich, wie gesagt, mein, mein zweiter Rechner, auf dem ich hier tippen kann, äh hat gerade kein Netz, deswegen ist im Kopf heraus, glaube ich, sind es äh zweitausend äh zweiundzwanzig äh bis dahin.
Dass jetzt läuft, also ich glaub aus dem Kopf heraus sind es vier, fünf Jahre, die jetzt sozusagen progressiv dieses Vorletztens entgelt gesenkt wird, bis es am Ende eben bei zwei Komma zwei ist. Und das, das Spannende ist aber, dass man jetzt eigentlich in Deutschland,
jetzt schon fast mit einem europäischen Tarif aus dem Ausland besser fährt, wenn man hin und wieder wenigstens sozusagen.
In einem anderen Land ist, sollte man das auf jeden Fall probieren.
Weil das große Problem des in Deutschland ist eigentlich, dass die Datenvolumen zu niedrig sind.
Wir sehen ja jetzt auch, dass.
Vodafone mit seinem neuen Angebot in dieselbe Kerbe schlägt, anstatt dass man das Datenvolumen für die Kunden erhöht, wie es im europäischen Vergleich längst überfällig wäre, schafft man dieses Programme.
Es den Kunden dann eben auch wieder nur erlauben ausgewählte Dienste zu nutzen.
Und diese Art von schafft einfach eine ist die schlecht für den Wettbewerb weil natürlich als Dienst der Anbieter gehe ich nur zu einem großen Mobilfunk an und schreibe mich dort in Verträge ein.
Und auch als Endkunde habe ich dann natürlich die Wahl zwischen überall niedrige Datenvolumen oder ich gehe zu so einem Serating äh Angebot.
Und in Wirklichkeit müsste die Bundesnetzagentur Stream On verbieten, um dann,
müsste die deutsche Telekom schon um ihre jetzigen Kunden nicht zu verlieren, die Datenvolumen erhöhen und das würde das Problem auch abschließend lösen und würde Deutschland endlich irgendwie auf ein vergleichbares europäisches Niveau bringen.
Ähm und äh das ist auf jeden Fall nur eine halbherzige Entscheidung, die trotzdem die Telekom unter Druck setzt äh und was jetzt hier passieren wird, ist, dass in dem Verfahren wird die Telekom auf jeden Fall versuchen.
Solange hinaus zu zögern, wie es irgendwie geht. Und weil sie auch um die Drossel kämpfen wollen. Auch beim Serating werden sie diese äh Lesarten nicht hinnehmen.
Und das Ganze wird ultimativ auch vor Gericht landen.
Und Vodafone und die Telekom werden auf jeden Fall an ihren Tarifen festhalten, deswegen liegt jetzt auch an der Telekom schnell Nägel mit Köpfen zu machen ähm und auch möglichst transparent zu sein. Wir haben.
Aber die Bundesnetzagentur wird auch irgendeine Frist genannt haben.
Also ich glaube, die offizielle Frist sind seit zwei Wochen. Ähm.
Und das heißt jetzt ist die Frage eben ähm ob die Telekom am um eine Verlängerung dieser Frist ansucht, ja? Ähm im Grunde müssten diese zwei Wochen jetzt im Oktober noch auslaufen.
Also theoretisch könntest du ihm jetzt irgendwie dieser Tage verboten werden. Ähm zumindest in der Form, wenn die Telekom nachbessert, äh aber wie gesagt das Ganze wird ultimativ sowieso vor Gericht landen.
Hilf mir mal so ein bisschen zu verstehen, weil ich grübel die ganze Zeit schon darüber, was eigentlich die Telekom.
Mal abgesehen jetzt von so einem Marketingeffekt. Vielleicht ist das auch der einzige, den sie äh sich wünschen. Ähm.
Davon hat. Also klar, ne? Also mit mit einem attraktiven Tarif, den die jetzt alle toll finden, könnten sie ja im Prinzip neue Kunden gewinnen. Ich würde mal sagen, darum geht's primär und das tun sie ja vielleicht auch, weiß ich nicht.
Telekom ist ja in Deutschland auch, sagen wir mal, was Datenvolumen betrifft, auch.
Ja eigentlich der schlechteste Anbieter sozusagen, also Vodafone ist da jetzt auch nicht so sehr viel besser. Sprich die beiden Großen.
Dir eigentlich die niedrigsten Volumina anbieten? Das heißt, die beiden Großen, es gibt ja eigentlich nur noch drei, also wir haben ja eigentlich nur noch.
Eigentlich nur so eine Trinität von Anbietern und O2 hat halt durchgehend bessere Angebote, dann gibt's noch diese ganzen Reeseller, die teilweise auch nochmal bessere Angebote haben.
Aber dann eben mit bestimmten Features, die nur die Telekom hat, äh, wiederum nicht
zum Beispiel diese lustige Option, dass man sich so für einen Tag für fünf Euro mal komplett frei kaufen kann. Es gibt auch einen unlimitierten
Vertrag glaube ich bei der Telekom in der Größenordnung von zweihundert Euro, ja? Also es ist jetzt nicht so, dass das gar nicht gäbe, sondern nur, dass die Preise dafür
erheblich viel höher sind als man das jetzt aus dem Ausland kennt, wo man teilweise für zwanzig, dreißig Euro skandinavischen Ländern
entweder sehr hohe Voluminau bis hin zu Flatrays äh äh erhält bereits. So, wenn jetzt also Telekom sagt, okay, wir machen jetzt hier so einen Tarif und die populärsten Angebote, wie zum Beispiel YouTube, wo ich mal fast vermuten würde, dass das so mal schon so gut
die Hälfte des nennenswerten Traffics ausmacht, weil das einfach so ein mega populärer Dienst ist und die Daten, die da rüber gehen, die halt auch nicht gerade gering sind.
Dann haben sie diese Kosten für die Daten ja ohnehin.
Ja? Also was, was, was würde es sie denn nennenswert noch extra kosten, diese Diskriminierung aufzugeben? Das verstehe ich nicht so richtig.
Ähm das ist
genau die Grätchenfrage, die es zu beantworten gilt und die eigentlich für die Bundesnetzagentur ausschlaggebend sein sollte. Ähm und zwar anstatt
jetzt einfach mehr Datenvolumen für die Kunden zu geben, weil die Tatsache, dass es Stream-On gibt, ist der Beleg dafür, dass A
Das Netz, die Kapazitäten für dieses Datenvolumen hat und B, die Leute schon längst dafür zahlen,
sozusagen auch durch die monatlichen Grundentgelte dieses Netz erhalten und ausgebaut werden kann. Äh und,
das heißt äh wir haben jetzt den Beleg dafür, dass äh die Leute schon längst für was zahlen, was sie nicht kriegen. Nur anstatt, dass die Telekom den Leuten einfach mehr Datenvolumen gibt, hat sie diesen Weg gewählt, ein komplexes System zu machen, wo,
sie die Kunden und die Diensteanbieter gegeneinander ausspielen kann,
im Grunde gegenüber äh den Diensteanbietern wie YouTube, wie äh Spiegel Online, die da alle dabei sind,
sozusagen mit ihrem großen Kundenstamm werben kann,
kommt zu uns, ihr habt dann die Pole Position gegenüber unseren vielen vielen Kunden äh und äh das ist für euch gut, weil dann euer Dienst mehr genutzt werden kann. Wir machen sogar Werbung für eure Marken auf unseren Produktseiten.
Und äh wir haben sozusagen hier einen Deal, der ist zwar nicht monetär, aber ihr bindet euch an uns. Ihr macht unser Produkt attraktiver und wir eures.
Und gegenüber der Kunden, den Kunden ist es dann einfach so, hm, ich will diese Dienste nutzen, ja? Das sind die großen Dienste, die ich jetzt gerade kenne und nutze und ähm.
Welchen Anbieter wähle ich nochmal? Ich kann jetzt irgendwie in Gigabyte rechnen, aber ich weiß vielleicht eh nicht, wie viel Gigabyte.
So Netflix äh Video ausmacht. Ich gehe zu einfach zu dem Anbieter, der mir Netflix dazu gib.
Und dadurch habe ich sozusagen eine Komodifizierung des Internets, das ist nicht mehr ein Universaldienst.
Sondern auch für den Kunden ist, dass Logo die Marke der einzelnen Diensteanbieter ein Anreiz für dieses Zugangsporto.
Und ähm die Telekom schafft es damit, sich in einer sehr einzigartigen Position am Markt zu bringen, ähm die sie gegenüber.
Beiden Seiten dieses doppelten Marktes sehr attraktiv macht. Und sie ist der Gateca.
Auch wenn andere Anbieter jetzt mit ähnlichen Produkten kommen und Vodafone Pass hat das ja jetzt schon getan, sind die nur noch die zweiten.
Noch dazu mit einem komplexeren System äh sehr viel schwieriger es haben werden da auf Augenhöhe zu kommen,
was die Anzahl an ähm Diensten.
Trifft. Auch was die äh Anzahl an Kunden betrifft, weil bei Vodafone muss sie auf einmal zahlen, um diese Pässe zu bekommen, um diese Dienste nicht mehr von meinem Datenvolumen abgezogen zu bekommen.
Und damit schafft man einfach eine eine Zementierung der Marktposition, kein kleiner Mobilfunkanbieter hätte so ein Produkt auf den Markt bringen können.
Das kann nur die Telekom. Und sie schafft damit natürlich auch sozusagen hinter sich.
'ne lange Betonspur, wo nichts mehr wachsen kann, weil bis irgendein anderer Anbieter da hinterherkommt, dauert es schon sehr lange.
Ähm und dadurch äh äh ist das jetzt einfach mal sowohl schlecht für den Mobilfunkmarkt,
wiegen auch schlecht für den europäischen Binnenmarkt und den Inhaltemarkt, weil ähm es ist halt einfach äh als als kleines Unternehmen,
oder auch als kleiner Radiosender sind jetzt zusehend auch Lokalradiosender bei Stream One dabei. Wie viele solche Seratingangebote kann ich abschließen.
Werde ich jetzt irgendwie auch mit einem äh österreichischen Mobilfunkanbieter vielleicht so ein Sirating Angebot anschließen.
Werde ich das irgendwie auch mit irgendeinem kleinen virtuellen Mobilfunker machen.
Wahrscheinlich nicht, weil die Vertragsbedingungen sind schon mal nicht kompatibel. Bei Vodafone kennen wir sie gar nicht, weil da muss ich zuerst ein Nondis Gloser Epremen, das ein Verschiedenheitsvertrag unterschreiben, bevor ich.
Tarifbestimmungen kenne, auch die technischen Bedingungen,
dieser verschiedenen Serating Angebote äh werden nicht kompatibel sein, sodass ich mich dann vielleicht auch technisch entscheiden muss, mache jetzt irgendwie zwei Versionen meines Dienstes
passe ich den regelmäßig an, mit all diesen Angeboten noch konform zu sein. Auf einmal habe ich nicht mehr dieses Grundprinzip des Internets,
Du bist vom Tag eins mit deinem Dienst global gleich gut verfügbar wie alle anderen.
Sondern auf einmal musst du Verträge machen mit jeden lokalen Wegeherrscher, der dieses lokale Netzwerk hat, um dort noch verfügbar oder gleichgut verfügbar zu sein. Da geht einfach das Grundprinzip des Internets verloren.
Noch dazu gibt's viele Dienste, die prinzipiell ausgeschlossen sind von Stream On. Also alles wo.
Du ohne DAM arbeitest, wo du Inhalte auch frei nutzen kannst, runterladen kannst außerhalb der App nutzen kannst, wo es vielleicht gar keine App gibt.
Stream on ist nämlich auch eingeschränkt auf Mobilfunkgeräte, so,
dürfte es theoretisch gar nicht tätern mit Stream on und dann sozusagen äh ähm das Netflix auf dem äh Browser von deinem Laptop äh äh sollte gar nicht gehen äh über Stream an, sondern,
nur in meinen Apps gedacht, wodurch auch die Gerätefreiheit angeschränkt ist, die auch in der Netzzentrale jetzt Verordnung steht.
Also hier gibt's viele negative Konsequenzen, die aber von der Telekom in Kauf genommen werden, weil sie sich damit selbst was Gutes tut,
Und äh das ist schon innerhalb von Deutschland hochproblematisch, weil jetzt einfach diese wirklich desoströse Volumensituation.
Die wir an der hätte sich jetzt was ändern müssen. Durch dieses Angebot werdet ihr wahrscheinlich noch ein paar Jahre lang,
damit leben müssen bis da irgendwer mal wieder mutig genug ist an ein Angebot zu machen, weil mit der Telekom jetzt zu konkurrieren, was keiner Anbieter.
Wird sehr schwierig sein.
Genau, das ist nämlich äh einen genauen Punkt, den man dann vielleicht nochmal betonen sollte, ne. Also man, auf der einen Seite wird ja bei Netzneutralität jetzt äh immer argumentiert, es sei ja nicht gut für die Anbieter eben.
Im Internet, ja? Weil die nicht gleich behandelt werden, aber es ist ja genauso auch ein Problem für die Vielfalt im Mobilfunk äh Bereich.
Aus dem von dir genannten Gründen und von daher ist das sozusagen in jeder Hinsicht doof.
Läuft's? Ähm, wenn jetzt diese,
was kann denn jetzt äh hast du da einen Einblick, wie äh wie sich das unter Umständen weiter eskalieren ließe? Also ich meine, wenn äh wenn hier gegen eine europäische Richtlinie äh.
Verstoßen wird. Wir reden von der Richtlinie, ne?
Wir Averin von einer Verordnung hier. Also es ist bindend. Und ähm wenn jetzt gegen diese Verordnung ähm
Verstoßen wird oder wenn's zumindest begründeter Anlass dazu besteht, dann müsste das Ganze ja im Prinzip äh von einem deutschen Gericht in Richtung Europa eskaliert werden, um dann äh Entscheidungen zu bekommen.
Das ist die Frage, also ähm wir sind in Vorbereitungen, die es.
Mehr kann ich dazu jetzt nicht sagen, wenn es deutsche Juristen gibt, die sich vor allem irgendwie so öffentliches Recht, Telekomrecht auskennen äh und da eben die deutschen Spezifika kennen, dürfen die sich gerne bei uns melden. Wir sind in
Vorbereitung für die Möglichkeit da irgendwie noch ein bissel nachzutreten.
Aber der Ball liegt immer noch bei der Bundesnetzagentur. Ich hoffe, dass das möglichst transparent gespielt wird. Ähm ich hoffe auch, dass es äh schon mal jetzt irgendwie.
Endlich Zahlen gibt über diese ganzen Sein-Abprozesse von Stream On und auch dann bei Vodafone Pars. Man merkte jetzt schon, dass Vodafone hier eine Verschwiegenheitserklärung verlangt
äh die die tun sie ja eigentlich nur wegen äh der Analyse von unabhängiger Seite, dass da jetzt irgendwie äh Steakholder wie Dats Politic Ork, wie die Verbraucherzentrale Bundesverband sich äh diese Produkte näher angeschaut haben
das will Vodafone vermeiden. Äh indem sie hiermit Vertragsstrafen drohen und ähm.
Ich ich will nur mal kurz auf die europäische Ebene kommen, ja? Ähm wir äh haben auch eine eine
Situation, dass das Ganze ja dann auch auf europäischer Ebene nicht durchzuhalten ist. Wenn wir uns überlegen, wenn man europäischen digitalen Binnenmarkt und jetzt gibt's überall in ganz Europa solche Sirating-Angeb.
Ähm ja, da muss ich irgendwie in vierundzwanzig Amtssprachen, Verträge abschließen mit äh potentiell tausenden von Internetprovidern, um noch verfügbar zu sein. Also
Grunde ist es auch eine Frage für die anstehende Novelle von besagter Netzentralitätsverordnung, dieses Problem zu erkennen und was dagegen zu tun.
Das muss dann, dass wir das nach der nächsten EU-Wahl sein, aber ich glaube, dass wir da auch auf eine Situation zu steuern, wo wo man mit einer,
mit einem Auge irgendwie sieht, dass das ein Problem ist und irgendwas dagegen tun muss. Ansonsten gibt's einfach bald keinen digitalen Innenmarkt.
Wie sieht denn das unser Komissar, der Herr Ansieb?
Der schweigt dazu noch. Ähm also mir werden da keine Aussagen bekannt
Kunde ist es auch eine Frage von Berak, von den europäischen Regulierungsbehörden
die müssen jetzt äh bis äh Ende des Jahres wahrscheinlich aber erst Jenner einen Bericht veröffentlichen, wo sie mal sich die Implementierung von Netzzentralität in Europa anschauen, der wird sehr spannend sein.
Und.
Ja, da da braucht's irgendwie eine schöne Gesamtschau darüber, äh wie denn dieses Gesetz, was ja eine Verordnung ist, also einheitlich in allen Ländern gelten muss, ob das auch einheitlich umgesetzt wird.
Und ich glaub der der stroße Zankapfel ist im Moment
gab es in Ungarn äh Entscheidungen äh die Sirating klar verboten haben. Ich glaube, die Ungarn sind die einzigen, die bis jetzt wirklich klar verboten haben,
aufgrund des neuen EU-Gesetzes ich verlinke hier auch die ungarischen Entscheidungen, falls es jemanden gibt, der die übersetzen kann, aufs Englische oder Deutsche wäre das.
Ähm äh und.
Im im Sinne des Lokbuches muss ich auch noch etwas vermelden, was keine gute Neuigkeit ist in den Niederlanden wurde nämlich ein Cirating Produkt kürzlich.
Erlaubt.
Äh die Niederlande waren ja lange der Vorreiter für Netzautalität, waren eins der ersten Länder in Europa, das erste Land, das Netzzentralität gesetzlich abgesichert hat und äh Tim Mobile hat es in ähm die Niederlanden geschafft
äh mit ihrem Data free Music äh durchzukommen. Das ist mehr oder weniger der Musikteil von Stream on. Ähm der dort ähm.
An den Markt gebracht wurde und äh ACM, die niederländische Regulierungsbehörde hat diesen Tarif durchgewunken
die lokale Netzpolitische Organisation hat aber schon angekündigt, dagegen in Berufung zu gehen. Und in den Niederlanden gibt's ja starke Traditionen von Netzneutralität, das ist den Leuten dort äh wichtig zumindest der Politik ähm am, aber eben leider nicht
der Regulierungsbehörde ähm und deswegen wird das auch spannend, wie das dann vor Gericht ausgehen wird.
Okay, also ich fasse äh zusammen, das ist alles jetzt noch gar nicht gesagt, dass äh es bei dieser aktuellen Situation bleiben wird, Stream und hat
Probleme eigentlich auf mehreren Ebenen, auch wenn die Bundesnetzagentur nicht unbedingt das kritisiert hat, was wir so primär äh sehen. Gibt's durchaus schon, gibt's durchaus schon äh.
Knifflige Anmerkungen insbesondere bezüglich des Roamings, also derzeit schließt ja der Tarif quasi diesen Betrieb außerhalb
Deutschlands aus, da gibt's ja auch bei der Telekom auch ganz unabhängig von Stream On, ähnliche Fälle, wie das von mir schon erwähnte, diese Day Flat, die man sicherschal
man kann ja für fünf Euro sagen jetzt bitte einmal hier unlimitiert, auch das wird im Ausland nicht angeboten, auch wenn ich hörte, dass man das sozusagen, wenn man das so über die Hotline geht, da auch schon andere Ergebnisse erzielen kann, ja? Also auch an der Stelle werden ja hier andere Angebote gemacht, die quasi auf europäischer Ebene dann nicht gelten
und ich könnte mir sogar vorstellen, dass es eigentlich ein ganz mächtiger Hebel ist, oder? Also.
Ist es, also ich würde auch jetzt äh immer stärker auf den, auf den europäischen Vergleich hoffen, also Deutschland ist ja einfach wirklich desaströses Schlusslicht und wenn man hier wir verlinken auch nochmal
den Digital Fuel Monitor, die haben einen schönen Ländervergleich, wo man auch sieht, wie abgerutscht Deutschland ist
Preisvolumenvergleich mit allen anderen Ländern in Europa und das Argument, das muss man einfach immer öfter bringen und dann hilft einem einfach auch die Tatsache, dass es immer mehr Tarife rund um Deutschland gibt, die um Welten billiger sind,
viel mehr Volumen anbieten und ähm wenn wenn immer mehr Leute aus Deutschland dann vielleicht auch mit zwei, drei Simkarten aus dem Ausland operieren, kann es sein, dass man immer noch billiger aussteigt,
Und äh das Schöne ist, dass das dann auch den heimischen ähm Netzbetreibern äh auf der Tasche lieg
da, also ich die, die kriegen immer noch diese Vorleistungsentgelte dann ähm einen Kunden, ja, stimmt
Sie verlieren die Kunden, sie, sie kriegen aber von den ausländischen Providern Geld. Aber es braucht hier einfach mehr Druck, das ist ein äh europäische Angleichung,
und ich glaub das Argument muss man einfach immer wieder machen und wenn uns Roaming am Ende hilft irgendwie mehr neutrales Internet für alle zu haben, auch für Deutschland
dann ist es gut.
Gut, kommen wir zu unserem letzten Punkt. Bezieht sich auch nochmal auf die Netzneutralität. Äh ist noch gar nicht unser letzter Punkt, sehe ich gerade.
Ich hab noch zwei ich ich will nur kurz auch wieder was Positives verlaut baden.
Ja, das ist gut, weil du weißt ja immer, unsere Hörer sind ja ohnehin immer schon kräftig äh gestresst von all den schlechten Nachrichten, muss man halt immer mal wieder auch so ein kleines Uplifting-Element einbauen.
Ja, ähm, das ist vor allem, was glaube ich für die, äh, für die Nerds ähm vor allem für die Netzwerktechniker innen. Ähm und zwar ähm.
Wir haben ja dieses EU-Gesetz gemacht, ja? Netzentralität gibt's jetzt, dann haben wir irgendwie diese Regulierung gemacht auf Berackebene, jetzt haben wir schöne Netzentralität.
Die muss man aber auch umsetzen.
Und wir reden jetzt viel über Sirating, es gibt aber auch technische Diskriminierung, also Provider können ja auch, wie wir das früher ganz oft hatten, einzelne Dienste blockieren, verlangsamen oder beschleunigen.
Die sogenannte technische Diskriminierung. Und damit man da drauf kommt, braucht man Daten.
Messsoftware und da gibt's jetzt eine positive Entwicklung. Ähm wer heute irgendwie
merkten, dieser eine Dienst ist immer langsam, äh dass äh Skype brückelt, äh dieser äh WhatsApp geht gar nicht zu meinem Mobilfunkvertrag, diese ganzen Phänomene
oder auch das zum Beispiel äh beteuernd gedrosselt wird.
Da gibt es jetzt eben auch 'ne gute rechtliche Handhabe dagegen in der neuen EU-Verordnung, nun muss man da drauf kommen, man muss technisch messen können, dass,
das eigene Internet eben verlangsamt ist, dass es Einzeldienste gibt die schlecht funktionieren.
Und eben vielleicht auch, dass man gar nicht das Datengarantie die Bandbreite bekommt, für die man eigentlich bezahlt. Ähm für all diese Fragen braucht man Messsoftware. In Deutschland gibt es da die Breitbandmessung der Bundesnetzagentur,
die ist meiner Meinung.
Desaströs schlecht und so ziemlich eines der schlechtesten Mess Tools, die es so gibt. Es gibt international äh bessere Software von äh Majorment Lab und auch von äh den den Netztest der RTR
äh und äh jetzt gibt es eben auch europaweit ein Projekt für die Erstellung von Messsoftware.
Und das ist was, wo wir uns auch im Hintergrund ganz viel eingebracht haben, wo es auch zwei schriftliche Stellungnahmen von uns gibt, weil wie wie messen das Internet. Man kann da irgendwie eine Blackbox hinstellen, wo ich dann aufn Knopf
klicke und dann habe ich eine äh Geschwindigkeit, die am Ende ausgegeben wird oder ich mache das alles schön Open Source Open Data und Modular.
Die europäischen Regulierungsbehörden haben sich jetzt für zweiteres entschieden und haben die Spezifizierung herausgegeben, die sehr stark unserer,
unserer Forderung entspricht der Zivilgesellschaft entspricht, nämlich dass man wirklich so ein Open Source Messsystem in Europa baut,
wo ich die zentrale Messinfrastruktur habe, wo es äh einzelne Tests gibt, die ähm die geschrieben werden,
das dann wirklich die Kunden, die Nutzer, äh, die Möglichkeit bekommen, ihren Internetanschluss von einem offiziellen Tool zu messen,
und das Ganze misst halt nicht nur die Geschwindigkeit, sondern auch ob gegen einzelne Dienste diskriminiert wird. All das fließt in einen,
europaweiten Open Data Pool, der offen zur Verfügung steht, das heißt die Interpretation dieser ganzen Messergebnisse liegt nicht bei den Regulierungsbehörden,
Das heißt auch unabhängige ähm Wissenschaftlerinnen und Zivilgesellschaft können diese Daten analysieren. Das heißt, ein Internetprovider, der auf einmal einzelne Dienste diskriminiert, hat immer das Damuckgeschwert über den Kopf, das ist Messdaten gibt, die,
diese Diskriminierung am Ende belegen kann. Äh das ist so ein bissel auch diese alte Vision des Wetterberichts fürs Internet und.
Da soll auch Geld in die Hand genommen werden von der EU-Kommission so ein System zu bauen.
Aber die, die Spezifikation, die da öffentlich wurden letzte Woche, die wir auch verlinken, die sind sehr positiv und.
Deswegen so ein kleines positives Ding noch am Rande zu dem.
Genau, verlinken wir in den äh Shownotes im Pressrelease und äh ich glaube, ein technisches Dokument auch, ne, was in etwa beschreibbar.
Genau. Ja, das beschreibt den Tender, ja? Das ist, das ist irgendwie so die technische Sache, ich
verlinke noch irgendwie so die Konsultation und die Inputs dazu vorher, die im technischen Spektalls. Wer äh sich mit diesem Thema ähm Messungen von Netzentralitäten, von von Netzwerk äh generell beschäftigt, der kann da wirklich einen Blick drauf werfen und äh.
Dann wenn's dann Meinungen gibt, freuen wir uns auch immer für einen technischen Austausch.
Schön. So und dann war noch was mit Mehmen.
Ja äh wir haben das, das ist so das Thema, was ich hier immer mit reinbringe, auch wenn ich ja überhaupt kein Urheberrechtsexperte
bin, äh, es gibt dieses diese Hinterlassenschaft von Günther Ettinger, äh der hat uns ja ein Urheberrechtsgesetz hinterlassen, das so ziemlich das Schlimmste ist, was man sich vorstellen kann und äh da drin enthalten sind auch Uploadfilter, also so 'ne,
europaweite Zensurinfrastruktur, die hier gebaut werden soll, um Urheberrechtsverstöße zu unterbinden.
Kann man sich so vorstellen, es gibt dann einfach.
Ein oder zwei großen Anbieter von solchen Upload äh Filtern in Europa und auf jedem Wikipedia-Eintrag, auf jeder E-Learning-Plattform, auf jedem äh Preisvergleichsportal, wo ich Fotos hochlade,
werden dann irgendwie meine Bilder, meine Musik und meine Videos gegen diese Upload-Filter getestet, ob da ja eh keine Urheberrechtsverletzung drinnen ist. Und so eine,
globale Zensurinfrastruktur soll in Europa gesetzt werden, äh die relevante Abstimmung,
im Juriausschuss des Europaparlaments ist für November angesetzt und es ist dringend notwendig, dass man sich da einbringt.
Wir verlinken die relevanten Kampagnen wo man das tun kann, save the mean und Change Coparit,
sind die zwei äh Pole Positions da, es gibt ganz viele Kampagnen, wir verlinken alles was man braucht um sich zu informieren und aktiv zu werden.
Weil äh wie gesagt, das ist nicht mein Kerngebiet, ich bin ja nicht Experte, aber ich verstehe genug, äh um um zu sehen, dass das wirklich so,
äh Gesetz wäre, was so viel Urüber nur durchkommen könnte und da aktiv zu werden wäre auf jeden Fall hilfreich. Ähm Julia Reder ist da irgendwie die Heldin, die sich im Europaparlament für uns einsetzt
und äh man müsste da wirklich äh nochmal bei den Abgeordneten ihnen ins Gewissen reden.
Die Verhandlungen laufen jetzt gerade zu diesem äh Gesetz und wir müssen schauen, dass wir da diese diese Uploadfilter noch gestrichen bekommen, ansonsten äh haben wir bald zu einer Infrastruktur wie in Russland oder in China,
Das ist auch immer für die Wikipedia sehr hart, äh, die, die wurden nur von diesen zwei Ländern gefragt, ob sie solche Uploadfilter einbauen,
wollen. Äh sie haben's in beiden Fällen abgelehnt und jetzt kommt Europa mit einem Gesetz daher, das genau das verlangt. Ähm das ist so die Tragwerte von von diesem Gesetz und deswegen wär's wirklich wichtig, dass sich da netzpolitisch interessierte Menschen,
noch einbringen.
Läuft's,
So, ich mache jetzt mal keine Musik. Wir haben noch einen Termin, der äh euch betrifft, haben wir ja auch schon mal erwähnt, können wir nochmal erwähnen, weil ist nächste Woche äh die Privacy Week findet äh statt, bist du da auch engagiert und Teil davon? Ich gehe mal schwer davon aus.
Äh ja, ja, wir sind da auch vertreten. Äh, es gibt ein Programm, es ist ähm zu das größte Netzpolitische Event in,
Österreich und wer in Wien ist nächste Woche die Woche vom dreiundzwanzigsten Oktober, der kann da mal vorbeischauen im Volkskundemuseum Privacy Week AT.
Mhm.
Ja, für mich wird's äh wieder mal schwierig, fit, äh, erneut auf meine eigene Veranstaltung vom vom Zeitrahmen her, ähm, gucken, vielleicht kriegt er noch einen Tag irgendwo rausgequetscht, sieht aber grad nicht so danach aus.
Die Subscribe falls jemand noch interessiert noch am Podcast geschehen Interesse hat, das ist ja hier durchaus auch noch ein Randaspekt dieser Sendung. Dann gibt's da das entsprechende Angebot noch in München, noch gibt's Karten. Ja.
Den Datenspuren in Dresden ist oder,
dem äh Mordsfest in London. Äh je nachdem, wann diese ähm Sendung erscheint. Äh und ihr seht mich, dann sprecht mich doch an. Ich freue mich auch immer, wenn ich äh Hörerinnen und Hörer kennenlerne.
Da können wir auch nochmal äh erwähnen, da ein Spuren ist jetzt dieses Wochenende, einundzwanzigster, zweiundzwanzigster äh Oktober, Privacy Week ist ähm.
Dreiundzwanzigster die ganze Woche äh bis ähm neunundzwanzigsten.
Ja. Und was hast du eben gerade noch erwähnt.
Ah die, die äh motzfest Mozzilla hat auch ein Event in ähm London äh
ich weiß nicht, ob wir hören in London haben, aber äh das ist auf jeden Fall auch irgendwie eine sehr lustiges, nördiges Event, wo es auch äh stark um Netzzentralität geht und äh da äh bin ich auch fast irgendwelche Leute in London sind. Ich mag diese Stadt sehr. Je
wo man da noch hinfahren kann. Das ist auch das nächste Wochenende, also vom siebenundzwanzigsten bis neunundzwanzigsten Oktober
Rouvensburg College in London.
Glaub dann haben wir's, oder?
Ja
Dann äh
Vielen, vielen Dank für die äh Auskünfte. Wir bleiben natürlich da am am am Draht und äh schauen, was äh was da noch so geht. Bisher äh haben wir ja eigentlich auch eine ganze Menge bekämpft bekommen
Ich glaube, die Karten stehen zumindest fast nur Neutralität äh betrifft nicht so schlecht, weil das alles so ein bisschen,
Nach Auslaufmodell auch aussieht, ne? Das sind noch so äh Kämpfe, die hier gefrorten werden. Ähm ich meine, in dem Moment, wo einfach.
Die Bandbreiten sich da anheben.
Und äh es ist einfach eine Normalität wird, dass das einfach zumindest für diesen normalen Audiovideobedarf einfach genug Netz da ist für alle.
Dann dann wird sich einfach diese Verknappung Knappung auch nicht weiter durchhalten äh.
Sehe ich genauso, also ich, ich hoffe auch, dass wir irgendwie eine Zentralität ist von allen netzpolitischen Themen, das, was wir noch am ersten,
wirklich lösen kann. Also das ist nicht so komplex, da reden wir nicht von Geheimdiensten und Urberechts Industrie eigentlich, sie sind nur Telekom-Konzerne und es ist eigentlich ein Verteilungsproblem
mit mit Glas und genügend Kapazität ließe sich das alles lösen. Ähm ich hoffe auch, dass wir irgendwann nicht mehr über dieses Thema reden müssen.
Das glaube ich allerdings auch. Jetzt hören wir auf jeden Fall erstmal auf damit. Ich sage tschüss und äh tschüss an alle Hörer, bis bald.
Mhm. Gut.